President Biden's big speech on the wars
in Israel and Ukraine missing the mark
the president getting slammed for and
mostly Meandering address full of
generalities and trying to link the two
conflicts together so let me share with
you why making sure Israel and Ukraine
succeed is vital for America's national
security you know history has taught us
that when terrorists don't pay a price
for their Terror when dictators don't
pay a price for their aggression they
cause more chaos and death and more
destruction Iran is is is supporting
Russia's UK in Ukraine and it's
supporting Hamas and other terrorist
groups in the region and we'll continue
to hold them accountable I might add we
cannot and will not let terrorists like
Hamas and tyrants like Putin win I
refuse to let that happen Biden's speech
not doing much to cool down the Muslim
World minutes before the president's
Prime Time address Rockets had a base in
Iraq where American troops were and a
new axio report says this quote never
before have we talked to so many top
government officials who in private are
so worried about so many overseas
conflicts it wants Biden however earning
High Praise from his former Chief of
Staff thank God Joe Biden's our
president not Donald Trump I thought
that what you saw tonight was a Savvy
and experienced president navigating
some very difficult uh territory doing
so in a way that was persuasive and
effective okay judge Janine do you think
Biden want to come to me
first do you think he was effective in
communicating why the American people
should get behind him in this project no
first of all I wanted to hear more about
the hostages I wanted to hear more about
the fact that Americans are are were
killed in Israel I didn't want to hear
about Ukraine I especially didn't want
to hear about Ukraine given the fact
that we gave them 200 million a week ago
and of the 100 billion he's promoting 60
billion for Ukraine 14 billion for
Israel I mean you know it was like he he
he he did exactly what I didn't want him
to to do yesterday I said I don't want
him leveraging Israel to give more money
to Ukraine that's exactly what he did
and I said I wanted America respected at
the end of that speech I wanted the
world to understand they were going to
deal with America the guy is just I mean
viscerally you look at him and you're
not afraid of him I mean he is he is an
example of how we don't have any power
but let me tell you something when he
tells Israel to restrain herself and not
be blinded by rage after what they did
to the innocent Jews and Israelis how
could he how could he possibly say that
and he says he's going to punish uh
Iran's going to pay a price you want to
talk about money how about you cut off
the funding and Ron claim how you can
even think that we're better off with
Joe Biden you've lost it okay Donald
Trump gave us the Abraham Accords Donald
Trump sanctioned he enforced the
sanctions against Iran Donald Trump
pulled us out of the Iran nuclear deal
when Obama was sending love letters to
them to say oh can we can work on this
thing together and um that there were no
beheadings when Trump was president and
the caliphate was destroyed when he was
president so I'm I'm we're in the middle
of two Wars right now on the verge of a
third we've got a one and a half million
Goda ways and we've got all kinds of
foreign Nationals and we got a clue guy
up there jumping around talking about
Indo Pacific and comparing I got one
more thing Ukraine to Israel here's the
difference Russia wants Ukraine the the
Arab world or the Hamas wants to not
just the Israel the land they want to
kill every Jew in sight that's the
difference he ought to understand that
Greg I forgot about the Obama love
letters do you think the Love Letters
might have fueled this attack on Israel
were these Love Letters to men oh to the
mullers oh sorry definitely not remember
that um there is something off-putting
about using a horrible event as part of
a package deal right I mean imagine
after 911 you know saying we also need
to fund a conflict in Iraq oh oh wait uh
but the the attack on October 7th should
stand alone and I think he it was like a
he took something new and ugly and
married it to something that's been
around like an arranged marriage between
a scared
and an old Rich dude so if you're
against Aid to Ukraine well then you
must be anti-israel I think this is why
we can't have nice things uh I don't
know this was the opposite of clarity it
should have been about the here and now
it should have been about October 7th
not a dragged out War which somehow our
interest mysteriously vanished from our
mental shelf space over a year ago I
mean do we the Ukraine war is such an
interesting War because how much do we
hear about it anyway we only hear about
it when one thing happens and then
another thing it's like not even a
consistent like where did it go well we
only hear about it when they ask for
more money for it yeah Jessica do you
think that Ron Clan was accurate when he
said that this was a Savvy presidential
address well I'd like to quote the
illustrious Brit
Hume
BR thank you Jessica this will be you're
very welcome this will be remembered as
one of the best if not the best speeches
of his presidency he was firm he was
unequivocal and he was strong now how
you felt about it definitely depends on
where you stand right now in terms of
Ukraine funding and this is something
that is splitting republicans in
Congress who think that this can't be a
blank check
forever but there is something to be
said for what President Biden was doing
in defining his strategy RIT large
versus just talking about Israel on its
own he didn't use the term a axis of
Evil but he essentially did Define a new
axis of Evil right Russia Iran Hamas and
China and we need to make sure that
their targets Israel Ukraine and Taiwan
something that we talk about all the
time that he's got to be tougher on
China are not incurred upon taking over
more massacres Etc
um The Love Letter front Kim Jong-un I
believe got the sweetest of Love Letters
From Donald Trump and autor beer who
died on Donald Trump's watch right he
came home and he was in a vegetative
state and his parents seeking Mercy for
their son took him off life support so
please don't give me this that
everything is all hunky dory while
Donald Trump Donald Trump brought him
home brought him home Obama okay anywh
who um I think that it is really
important that he and I know it was a
major kind of sticking point and we're
going to talk about in the next block as
well that President Biden not only
called out anti-Semitism but talked
about as islamophobia and Greg says we
need to live in the present and I agree
with you and said it multiple times
today you got to start every
conversation with this is what Hamas did
to Israel but after 911 not only did we
make tremendous military mistakes we
made tremendous mistakes at home we put
cops in mosques and surveilled these
people we did racial profiling up the
Wazoo and treated the moderate Muslim
population in this country as if they
were all about to be arrested for a
crime that they did not commit and I
don't want to repeat of that and there
is a six-year-old dead Palestinian
American boy who was murdered because of
islamophobia in this country and that
he's the president for all Americans and
that includes the Muslim population
Jessica the comparison though between
right crazy and left crazy is a bit
weird your crazy is based in structures
of Academia medical establishments now
entertainment media this oneoff nutbag
who should get the death penalty for
killing that Muslim child is a crazy
person but he's not on the Colombian
faculty he's not a politician part of
the squad he's just a crazy nutbag who
should be killed I agree and also with
respect to the to the two siding thing
that we're now seeing I don't see
thousands of people in the streets
chanting kill all the Muslims I do see
them chanting kill all of the Jews and
death to America I want to say one thing
that caught my attention during Biden's
speech which was so ridiculous and
infuriating at a time that we're in when
he brought up the two-state solution
yeah um the delusional Ivory Tower idea
about the two-state solution with who
with Hamas in Gaza with the Palestinian
Authority who released a call to the
imams in the west bank today to talk
about killing Jews in their sermons or
should it be Islamic Jihad who is trying
to fight a civil war with the
Palestinian Authority because they're
not they're too moderate their their Jew
hatred and anti-israel hatred is too
moderate it's an it's an academic idea
that has been floated for far too long
it should be dead in the water because
Israel clearly cannot be neighbors with
any of these people who are in the
streets celebrating what happened on
October 7th and they celebrated it after
911 as well let's not forget that so
this idea that he just threw in this
two- sides issue of a two-state solution
at a time when Israel hasn't even
invaded Gaza to avenge what has been
done was just a distraction and it's not
helpful in fighting the evil that
continues not just in the Middle East
but that we're seeing pop up on college
campuses all over the country thank you
kitty hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else